playing with live instruments has always
just been more comfortable for me
to pick apart a song and build a song
and layers is a lot easier for me to get
across what I'm trying to get across
I've always been a fan of arranging
music and I got with Peter Cottontail
who I had known for years he produced a
lot of stuff for me and he goes to Gaul
and Nate Fox and Styx and just my
closest friends and redid a lot of the
songs for the live show and I fell in
love with arranging and producing and
working with those guys and since then
we've always tried to do big production
stuff and work with more players
whenever we play shows we like to flip
the arrangement just to keep it fun
[Music]
it's all like a big group and family of
people the Chicago Network is really
strong but also like the musicians
Network is huge and we treat each other
as not just guys in the same damp alike
as life counterparts and people that we
like to exist around and grow around so
I got two nominations for my ride on the
life of Pablo Kanye's album like that's
an unbelievable thing you know I never
thought that I would be nominated for a
Grammy for working on Kanye's album
because he is like the originator of art
to me somebody that made me think art is
cool and to be outspoken and confident
is cool one also to be sensitive like
the word sensitive wasn't cool to me
before that I think being sensitive and
being knowledgeable and understanding
and having emotion is important
[Music]
the idea that a bunch of people with
different ideas but the exact same goals
to come together mostly from Chicago and
sing with faith and with fervor and put
hours in and and be so uncertain but yet
still so faithful and be recognized by
an institution like the Grammys I mean
everybody that worked on the project
which is literally over a hundred people
evolved you know been in a different
space since we found out and yeah it's a
it's a beautiful time in my life